the russell i was is dead i am now
a conglomerate of of my former self and
this thing that's that's yeah that's
intentional
hey what's going on everybody from first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today i'm excited
to welcome russell brand back to the hot
seat
he's a comedian actor and writer his
latest project is the audible original
revelation connecting with the sacred in
everyday life which is currently
available
exclusively with audible and not to be
outdone he has a youtube channel as well
proud to say i'm a longtime subscriber
russell brand welcome back to the show
well i suppose in a sense i feel very
much like michael corleone
in godfather part three which not as
many people watch but was defined
perhaps by the line just when i think
i'm out
they pull me back in again and that's
how i feel about hot ones i thought that
was behind me i thought i'd conquered
every kingdom there was to conquer
i feel like i got to the end of it and
sung a spontaneous opera
but here i am again with this spicy
battalion
lined up before me and then i'm not sure
how much of this story you even know but
you know in these times we have to send
the sauces out to people's homes and
your sauces
actually got caught up in customs i
don't know if that's a byproduct of
post-brexit britain or what
but i had a panicked phone call early in
the early morning
hours and we were actually able to
connect with a local hot sauce store who
not only provided this substitute lineup
but also did so with a bunch of classic
hot ones labels
that are all in their exact spot
including da bomb
so hop burns in black in london thank
you
for saving today's episode you can rely
on the english to step in when there is
a little bit of spice required
and i'll thank you sean not to
politicize this those who dare
blame brexit if anything blame the
pandemic but but brexit no way brexit's
making spicier than ever
british spice
[Music]
all right so for me it'll be the classic
for you
it'll be the howler monkey original i
see i've got that
[Music]
did you see the potential back then are
you just as shocked as i am that this
thing's still going
no i think that it is a testimony to
your talent
i think that the unsung spice is sean
wow russell yeah
so your new audiobook revelation
explores the meaning of life
death and all the sacred things that
connect the beginning to the end
and i don't think that it's a
coincidence that the people that you
hear
spreading the spiritual teachings of
people like ram das or muji
are comedians like yourself pete holmes
and joe rogan
is comedy a gateway drug to spirituality
yeah that's a really good point maybe it
is potentially because
comedy requires that you don't take life
seriously
and that is a sort of a powerful
spiritual motif the figure of the
trickster recurs throughout different
mythologies because the tricks though is
kind of like an ambivalent
deity or messenger neither not fully
good not fully bad capable of beauty
capable of stupidity and i suppose like
if you're always looking at the world
and questioning it and querying it
as good comedians do and i hope that's a
category i belong in
then eventually you start to see life is
a kind of a game
and that's like like you know in the
vedas and in indian or like you know
sort of
pre-indian literature spiritual
literature life is a play it's a game
it's not real it feels so real because
the emotions feel so real
the hot sauce feels so real on the
tongue but what is actually happening in
the brain
and what is experiencing the heat
so like i mentioned in your intro i'm a
disciple of the russell brand youtube
channel which started more than eight
years ago and has since ballooned to
have over three million subscribers
is someone with interesting thoughts on
the intersection of fame social media
exploitation what were your first
thoughts or like your first impression
of like youtuber culture
it made me feel that you know like every
time one of these
new technologies emerges and creates his
stars
i recognize my own place in the culture
i recognize the move
the move from luke skywalker han solo to
much
more obi-wan territory hence the attire
it's impossible for us to be objective
about a figure like
elvis presley now and how much his
success was as a result of the success
of radio the emergence of television
and of course we're just seeing versions
of this happening
again and again i think it's the same
thing with tech stuff
like you know from the journey from
facebook
to tick-tock like you know i think like
facebook now
looks like some old-timey saloon bar
with one of them pianos
playing itself like tick tock stretched
straight away
like i looked at it for a bit and i just
felt that i'm
i'm was just an elderly decrepit man
i took it off my phone immediately i
thought this is there's nothing for me
here
i'm old i'm an irrelevant i should never
ever look at that again
it's like they're just looking through a
window and catching my own reflection
as a wizard thing
when i picked up this i felt something
in my abdomen
the fiji fire as it coated the tongue
it was like a sort of a sort of a
littering of napalm
in the early early days of an
ideological
war in a foreign territory we're not
fully
at atomic levels but we're starting to
say we know this is not going to be a
nice war this is not the old days of
chivalry
and swords so a blind spot in our last
interview was your career in stand-up
which in the early days was this
antagonistic
avant-garde stuff and in your memoir my
bookie book you talk about the days
of being chased out of comedy clubs by
angry mobs
what is the most harrowing onstage
experience you can ever recall having
there's several that come to mind up in
scotland bonnie scotland
i was making some sort of complex um
what was i saying sort of allusions to
our
joint culpability for uh
you know say sort of social anomalies
such as murder say oh if one person was
committing a murder perhaps we were all
culturally responsible
people didn't like that it led to a big
convert like because i didn't say it
that way i said you are responsible for
child murder because i think how it came
out as words
i recognize that what happened to me is
when the security came out they got me
in a real naked choke
i felt my windpipe closing up and it
totally changed my perspective on the
situation
yeah i went from yeah yeah coming it's
all right okay it's over sorry
very very quickly so those were kind of
things that happened
with increasing regularity and i must
say expediated the process of me
stopping taking cracking hearings i was
thinking it was starting to affect my
lifestyle
[Music]
i'm beginning to feel sort of like what
i would call vaguely psychedelic
effects now in 1968 canadian philosopher
marshall mcluhan said
when you give people too much
information they resort to pattern
recognition
what if at all do you see as the
consequences of being
overly informed well that your man seth
abrahamson talks about that
meta journalism now you know like that
now there is so many sources so much
data
that what you require of a journalist is
a kind of curating like you know we've
pulled together all of these sources all
these surveys all these interviews and
we've created this narrative from it
you know marshall mcluhan was practicing
most famous quote media is the message
was sort of
made prior to the point where we all had
our own private portals to sort of
relatively bespoke but
ultimately controlled media outlets in
our hands
but all of these various historical
narratives in this complex geopolitical
era
all trying to live together in one
person's head when we're evolved to live
in tribes of 75 to 150 people
you know we live for hundreds of
thousands of years as hunter-gatherers
before
agriculture industrial revolution
technological revolution
so opinioned us into a life that we're
not evolved for
this is we're monkeys you and i and here
we are
doing a hot sauce competition thousands
of miles away from one another
challenging british customs it can't be
right can it
at the level of the soul sean
[Music]
they're becoming thicker at my end i
don't know if that's a good thing or not
now that's on my fingers i'll touch an
eye oh god i've overdone it i've
overdone it yeah be careful like icarus
be careful got too close to the sun
that's yeah that's intense
all right russell brand we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that gram where we do a deep
dive on our guest instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context so i'll show you the picture you
just tell us the bigger story
i've read that you have something like
60 000 bees at your countryside home
but i'll get i got i had for a little
while a little b town
like you know i'm a vegan and stuff when
i took that thing out
i didn't feel like it was right to take
their honey they've worked so hard so i
go
let's just let them get on with it i
like getting on the outfit it's
ghostbusters
it's cool it's nice it's nice to feel
impervious to bees like that
perhaps there's something analogous to
our species here if you leave them alone
and just say crack on b
you be you bees they just [ __ ] off but
they didn't want
freedom they wanted to have a tyrannical
overlord going in there stealing their
honey
and when that process ended sure they
just upped and left and started their
own life somewhere else i've never seen
them again they don't call
i get nothing from them but i kept that
beekeeper suit and thank god i did
because there was a wasp attack at my
house wasps were building like nests and
stuff
and then wasps they crossed the line
they attacked the family shaun they made
it personal it was like taken
or taken to or any bronson movie you'd
care to name
i've donned that suit one last time i
swore i'd never wear a suit again
but even then actually i wore little
crocs you know backless crocs
and the wasps they're clever little
[ __ ] they found that naked hill
on the back and they attacked that
they stings on stings so my favorite b
fact is they need authority my favorite
wasp fact is make sure you cover
every inch of your body because they're
very sensitive and alert to what's what
here you are on the set of ballers with
dwayne johnson
how much of your alpha male showdowns on
that show were
improvised and if so are there any
highlights that stand out to you
if you're gonna really take your alpha
male showdowns to
to a place where they're likely to be
challenged why not have one against
dwayne the rock johnson
the world's biggest most handsome and
successful man
and if you want to really give it an
edge how about this on day two of
filming mate
the director julian ferrino he goes um
you're really great today we thought
tomorrow for that scene on the beach
wouldn't it be funny if you
took off all your clothes and walk naked
into the sea
i told dwayne johnson he's a producer on
that show because i'm a bit nervous
about
walking naked to the beach and he he got
the crew and background eyes to
create a human corridor down the beach
because there's paparazzi there for
the rock not for me you know like a
human corridor of people
for me to walk down a big and during
that moment there's no real acting
required to walk in the new to a beach
so i just use that time to think about
the absurdity of reality
to think if this is real then what is a
dream if this is real how does the
world make sense i'm walking down a
beach with my hopefully not dimpled
[ __ ] gary buses over there the rocks
over there
this is actually real and it's happening
in infinite space
and there are neutrinos rushing through
our bodies right now
undetectable unless you go into labs at
the earth's core
what the hell is reality what is it
[Music]
i'm hearing my own rants and they're
getting crazier
[Music]
do you ever have you know there's the
oral impact
but what about the gastric and even
colonic impact
down the line is that something you can
speak to russell you know like
the body adjusts so at this point i'm
immune for you it might be another story
thankfully the cameras will have left
for the for that
aspect of the story a man hunched in
shame
the british broadsheets always used to
work people into a frenzy about how
dictionaries were losing words like
marzipan and abby for words like blog
and chat room
is someone who seems to enjoy deploying
the full breadth of the
queen's english what do you think when
you see or hear stories like that
that's the point of it to evolve and
grow only the things that there are
words for
are being said so the more effective
language becomes
and i'm only speaking the english
language it's the only one i know the
better i like it and i think that
language can be co-opted colonised
and used to
[Music]
exclude certain people from particular
cultural conversations so
i think that language must be
democratized and even though i like sort
of old greek latin derived words i
love slang there are people that speak
dialects in your country i think are
just so beautiful to hear and in my
country like slang based
dialects are sort of joyful like i spoke
to some real
about some 20 year olds at some sort of
kind of school for
school for the naughty and like uh like
the like i just felt like wow i feel
like i'm shouting down a tunnel made of
years
you know like like and even the words i
was using that i thought were cool
for them my mother is saying oh i've got
a lovely penny farthing bicycle outside
yeah this if i wind up my wrist watch
here that tick
you know i mean like i feel like i was
gandalf
[Music]
a disclaimer if i may say it says may
cause anal leakage
it says it's gluten free oh thanks but
my
anus is leaking i'm not worried about
allergies if i can't control my colon
this looks like some serious stuff i
must confess
working our way up
what was your favorite decorative accent
or piece of wall art from nicholas
cage's house you write about
living there for a while when you guys
were filming army of one
oh man like i mean i don't want to
betray nicholas cage's
privacy because i did a movie with him
called army of one as you've tagged
don't worry no one did and like when i
like
he was such a lovely guy at nicholas
cage and he was directed by larry
charles who's also like an amazing dude
so i was hanging out in
morocco with these two like amazing men
then nicholas cage during that goes do
you like want to stay at my house and i
went oh my god i'd love to
there were some incredible artifacts in
there some incredible
mysterious pieces of i suppose perhaps
he wouldn't mind me saying that there
was a stained glass window
that looked like a bit like king arthur
but also a bit like
nicholas cage and i didn't ever tell him
this at the time but i did
watch a lot of nicholas cage movies
while i was in his house i watched like
con air adaptation i went on a real
nick cage journey there and i must say
like he was a
really cool generous lovely person
i really overstayed my welcome in that
house i was there for six months i mean
at the end of it people saying could you
please get out now
this isn't your house
[Music]
now what i think is interesting is like
you know i feel like i've got that
you know sort of stockholm syndrome now
but that this has become such a
particular
experience for me doing this is that i
can't imagine going back to my life even
though it's only over there
you know like this is my reality now i
do feel connected
this one's crazy
i can i can feel it trying to get into
my nervous system
yeah this one really becomes a part of
you
the russell i was is dead i am now a
conglomerate
of of my former self and this thing
that's that's yeah that's intense [ __ ]
i understand that as a process in the
process of changing your lifestyle
moving to the countryside one of the
things that you did was change your
phone number
is there one person who'd be who you'd
be most upset to learn
has been trying to call you but can't
hold me because i'm dealing with some
more of this conflict
and there's still two more kingdoms to
visit we have two more kingdoms to
go check out that water has a flavor now
it's like i can feel the individual
molecules in it
[Music]
the body's not real sean it's an
illusion
i'd be worried if i'd found out that
somehow lost the opportunity to speak to
jesus
that would trouble me but i feel like he
would find a way
it's it's suffering like if this was
actual food
now like if this wasn't framed as hey
we're doing this thing
where we deliberately eat hot sauces in
a kind of gentle
test about mcchismo i would
be saying that shouldn't be classified
as food that should be classified as a
weapon
i agree with you a hundred percent are
you ready to move on here
i don't know the look of that medusa um
what's happened is is the um time has
concertina because my anecdotes about
here on gracie and
nick cage was so long but now just being
carpet bombed
i just did a burp and it disturbed a bit
that must have been in the spongy tissue
on the top of my tongue you got to be
careful we're trying to allow it to go
dormant
what if some of the mix it could
actually be like destabilizing like
uranium or something yeah [ __ ] man
[Music]
why are you breathing like that i have
to cop the same way
right i'm scared of this because this is
like
this is like i mean shooting yourself in
a bullet hole
but we're almost the end we're almost to
the end
i'm trying to find new bits of my my
mouth that aren't damaged you know
so a lot of children's classics from dr
seuss to roald dahl
come under scrutiny for various reasons
have you had any takeaways from the
children's books that you've read to
your kids
it's difficult when sort of your
personal history
which you might regard sentimentally as
positive
is sort of lately redefined as negative
from a broader or different cultural
perspective
but i um
you know i've not read anything and
thought a minute that's not right but
we're pretty conscientious about what we
introduce them to
when i improvise most of the stories
anyway and i really try to make sure
there's a lot of
strong pan-cultural positive
feminist messaging going into those
stories as best as i can i mean i think
i could come up with something
magnificent
at the moment but it's not something i
would commit to camera
[Music]
there's no last dab in the uk so this is
actually
sourced from scotland so it's called the
singularity sauce company
reapers and mangoes hot sauce why have
they packaged it as an
inoffensive way i mean look the others
got the juices on it's skulls that looks
like it could be the
interior of a doll's house this could be
a teletubbies day spa
but you're assuring me that it's a
vindictive condiment
oh [ __ ] i've tipped too much it's it's
runnier than his predecessors
russell
[Music]
it's her majesty the queen of england
to the queen to the queen
[Music]
oh yeah it's making his way to the nose
hole
russell brand here we are at the
conclusion of our oral jihad and i'm not
sure if you recall but you closed out
the show last time
with an impromptu freestyle tribute song
to hotman's super fan brett baker
and it's a moment that's lived in lore
for day one hot ones fans for me
personally
a top five moment in the history of the
show and i know for brett baker our
little list maker
it was a life-changing event so now that
you're back on the show i want to
introduce you guys
face to face can we bring in brett baker
oh wow hello boys that's all right
brett britt how i've rehearsed this
moment in my dreams how beautiful it is
well that makes two of us it is my
dearest wish that when i pass from this
mortal coil you and i are blended into
one source my dying wish is that sean
samples us dips
you can use any part of our anatomy as
the dipping cup i don't mind it doesn't
have to be bad taste
but that i think is our shared destiny
to become a source together
well hey look i want to go back to four
years ago
when you perhaps unknowingly changed my
life
forever with a 90-second impromptu song
and owed to me a plea to be on top of
the leader table
which you were for a number of months
because well
let's face it i can be bribed by
attention and congratulations
but you did that in a pretty intimate
set with no music whatsoever
off the top of your head not knowing who
brett baker was when you walked into
that room
where for you does that kind of ability
to to channel that that emotion or that
energy
where does that come from or do you even
understand kind of like
maybe where that comes from or just just
let loose and go
baker who understands these songs i make
now that shawn's become a dalai lama
justin timberlake and as i see you there
in front of your trophies and nfl
sweethearts what a lovely couple of
cool bald cats your tongues are hot
and your bodies are better you're making
my bum
cool my willy's getting wetter oh bread
baker i'd love to take you on a journey
back to albany
albion arcadia england though hear my
song fred baker can
love ever be wrong oh may
cass hawk break his heart and make us
hot on our tongues
make us old make us die make us feel
really young
if life is just a circle if we are just
jerks
then let's make it work
i mean you know brett it's uh i don't
know where it's come from and i don't
know where it's going
extremely pure gentleman such a
wholesome moment
another one of my favorites and it's
happening in real time you just have to
absorb it you just have to feel it you
just have to know it
and look at you russell brand for the
second time taking on the wings of death
and coming out victorious now my friend
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you
this camera that camera probably just
the one you're looking at let the people
know what you have going on in your life
oh yes my audible original and that's
what we call it revelation
is available only on audible my podcast
under the skin is available on luminary
my youtube channel as beloved sean has
mentioned is available
on youtube please involve yourself
engage yourself with that content some
of it's free i try and keep it free as
much as i can but sometimes
i need money for lifestyle reasons and
sometimes for oral surgery which i'm
going to have now
good job russell good job but russell i
just want to say from the bottom of my
heart thank you
very much because you'll never know
really how much you have blessed me with
that 90 seconds
four years ago it's been tremendous and
uh and i i owe you a lot
thank you you're a really really sweet
man i've got nothing but love for you
mate thank you very much for saying that
thank you for your sincerity i
appreciate it
hot ones fans sean evans checking in to
say thank you so much for watching
today's video and would you look at that
one of the chili world's heavyweights is
back
hot ones the last dab carolina reaper
edition will be
in the april hot one subscription box
heatness.com
heatness.com.com to sign up and for more
information
hot ones the last dab carolina reaper
edition
get it while it's hot
you